when you wrote Rehema has lost her home
and she's sick from malaria her mother's
doing her best to keep her safe in this
temporary camp in Northeast Kenya the
baby has been really sick we went to the
hospital and they said she had malaria
they asked for money to give her
medication but we didn't have any so he
came back home she hasn't slept she's
sick and cries a lot when the seasonal
rains swept through her village near
Karissa rising flood waters from the
Tana River submerged her home with the
floods came many mosquitos putting the
people there at risk of malaria it's a
life-threatening disease in hot humid
climates across African countries
mosquitoes spread a parasite that's
infected nearly 230 million people in
2018 400,000 died in a statement Kenyan
president Uhuru Kenyatta says they've
been able to lower malaria prevalence
from a high of 6 million infections to
4.6 million over the last 10 years this
progress is a result of support and
cooperation between the government
development partners and frontline
health providers Kenya has joined Ghana
and Malawi in a pilot vaccine program
that's focusing on the worst-hit areas
but with countries responding to the
corona virus pandemic the World Health
Organization says this could directly
impact the number of malaria cases it's
urging governments to take action we
need to our the distribution of our
vector control tools we need to remain
open and facilitate access of pregnant
women to prompt diagnosis and treatment
of malaria and in Garissa without the
means to give Rehema medicine her mother
has no choice but to hope she's strong
enough to fight off the disease herself
Lord Buddha Manly al-jazeera